of all the ones you're doing yeah how
much do you enjoy the most like is the
most fun for you well okay so you
mentioned Charlie the Trump one it's
funny because that one really only
started to blow up on social media like
five months ago so I was trying to do it
and I'll tell you I've been trying to do
it and I was failing like a dog nothing
was happening we were posting more than
anyone seen will you shut your mouth he
is such a nasty guy Paul versus no one
knows what it's called but I was posting
a lot and the beautiful thing about this
one is that people try to do it and they
fail no one can do it yeah and uh that's
a very therapeutic thing because you
could say what you want you can say
whatever you want you can say whatever
you want for example Paul looks like
he's a bouncer and could kill somebody
okay you don't want to [__] with Paul he
said do not do not mess with Paul he's a
dog and he knows
[Applause]
he laughs like he's being choked in the
bedroom he's got a wheeze like no one
see look at him music
look at him wheezing